[Music]
now the media's phoning coverage of dr
flip-flop bauchi has officially really
jumped the shark if you will gone too
far he's now being dubbed a movie star
by the new york times because national
geographic produced a new documentary
entitled fauci details his work with
aids and coven 19 pandemics and the
so-called paper of record highlighted
one scene where fauci described quote
himself as a modest and humble person
okay that means he's almost as wrong
about himself as he's been about covert
19. you know the reaction the author of
for such a time outnumbered co-host uh
kaylee mcinany and outkick founder clay
travis kaylee i got a look at your book
congratulations um let's start with you
uh is he a tv hollywood star
yeah in his mind he is look he is
portrayed as a movie star who can
artfully navigate washington
sean i know this guy i crossed paths
with him at the hallway you know he was
in my office this is not a movie star
who can artfully navigate washington
this is a person who is a con artist who
can swim in the washington swamp with
the worst and most vicious of creatures
he's like general milly he'll smile at
you in the hallway he'll give you a wave
he'll have that congenial chat but
behind the scenes he will undermine the
commander-in-chief and then he'll step
to the white house podium and undermine
the commander-in-chief in front of the
world
for the world to see because it behooves
him and increases his hits on cnn msnbc
even facebook this man never met a
camera he did not like dr fauci not a
movie star though in his head it may
seem so and clay first it's masks don't
work no masks and it's one mask and it's
two masks then it's vaxxer mask now it's
vax and mask and get booster shots and
your kids need it and you'll probably
need masks and booster shots in
perpetuity you figure that out
sean it was 15 days to stop the spread
now it feels feels like 15 years until
fauci will leave the screens he's never
met a camera he doesn't like i mean it's
crazy although this is a little bit
ironic i don't know if you've requested
him on your radio show sean but buck
sexton and i decided to request him on
the radio show and they said oh you know
what he's too busy he doesn't have time
to spend 15 minutes with us we just
wanted to ask him about it with me early
on but now that he's been exposed
the nih money going to the wuhan lab and
the fact that he was told january 31st
2020 it looked like it was manipulated
in a lab he might not want to answer
those questions clay
oh i think you're right
it's amazing how much he doesn't want to
do media when they'll actually ask him
questions that are worthy of being asked
but he can go on msnbc and cnn i think
they basically got a green room named
after him over there but he can't do
anybody that's actually going to ask any
legitimate questions of them all right
quickly in 30 seconds kaylee tell us
about your book
can't wait for it to come out for such a
time as this my faith journey through
the white house and beyond i tell you
how president trump's the real deal not
through saying it but through stories
that will bring you behind the scenes of
the most powerful building in the world
the white house thank you sean and you
know what the amazing thing is you had a
front row seat to history i guess um i
think i'll take those mean tweets over
the utter incompetence and abandoning
americans chaos at the border begging
opec inflation higher taxes and uh a
mitigated economic disaster but that's
my own preference thank you both hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else